I'm gonna be honest with you guys I saw
an ad a billboard for the Croods and it
looked like it was going to be like the
stupids for cavemen I was really wrong
[Music]
the Croods so the cruise is the story of
this cave family Nicolas Cage plays the
dad of the Croods and he talks like
Nicolas Cage you know he really talks
like this you know no we can't go
outside because there are things out
there that'll eat you he talks like
Nicolas Cage in this movie there's no
doubt in your mind you're like this is
Nicolas Cage and the Croods have
survived thus far because they're a
really careful family like alright don't
go outside don't get curious don't look
at anything don't touch anything and at
first I was like this movie's gonna bore
me everything is really brown and they
don't do anything but then they meet
this cave guy named guy and he's his
young dude the chick crude chick has a
crush on this guy and he's voiced by
Ryan Reynolds which means he's funny and
then they all tumble off a cliff into
the land of Pandora from Avatar and now
they're on an adventure that to step
outside their comfort zone and then I
was like holy [ __ ] I'm really enjoying
this movie the movie was cute it was
funny it was relatable family wise and
culturally it was just really relevant
it has that humor that adults will get
and kids will get and I like the family
the Croods themselves usually in a
family like this you're like alright you
two I like you too the rest are pretty
stupid this useless one is the wife but
she's not useless because she's the wife
of the dad
voiced by Nicolas Cage so she's relevant
to him he's relevant to everybody in
this new element this guy comes in and
everyone's like oh you're cool and of
course poor mr. Cruz like now rules rule
save us it's really a story about how
adapting to change is how you're going
to survive in life it's an important
lesson to learn I really dug that about
this movie I like the creatures in this
movie too because they have elements of
creatures that we know today but they're
so opposite elephants are mice and
rhinos or birds and [ __ ] like that it's
like every animal has the features of
two different kinds of animals fused
into one they're like they're Wuzzles
that's what they are
bumble lion is somewhere in this movie I
miss my bumble lion that's right it used
to be all Pixar Pixar was like we're
Pixar we do everything right now
DreamWorks Animation is a force to be
reckoned with it's not just Pixar
anymore and that's I like a competitive
world I swear to you couple times in
this movie I did tear
yeah I went to this movie thinking it
was going to be the stupids
but cavemen and I was like gee it's not
the stupids this movie was great it was
funny it was witty it was relatable I
highly recommend it if you have kids and
you don't think your kids are quite
ready to see Olympus fall take him to
the crude you will all have a good time
with it I will say the Croods is
certainly worth saying I would buy it on
blu-ray so what's your favorite
DreamWorks Animation not Pixar
DreamWorks we're going to give them
their own question today whatever it is
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more
[Music]